Think about the single button
that we want to place on screen.
I've drawn the button here in green,
and the view in blue.
Let's assume we want it on
the center of the screen,
regardless if our app is running
on an iPhone or an iPad Pro.
The button should always be in
the center, even when the app is on
different device orientations,
from portrait to landscape.
Constraints are the rules
that tell iOS how to position
inside this particular UI element.
So, if we were to think of placing
the record button on the center,
we need a distance from the top, the
distance from the bottom, distance from
the leading, and finally, the distance
from the trailing edges of the view.
If you're following along,
you're thinking, okay, four constraints.
And it would be correct except most user
interface elements have what we call,
an intrinsic size.
That is they have a built-in height and
width.
In the button's case, this height and
width is automatically calculated
based on the text and font size you
selected for the button's text.
If iOS knows the height and width of
a UI element, like a record button,
then it only needs half the constraints
to size and position it.
That is to say,
if I tell iOS how far from the top
of the screen the button will be,
then it can automatically calculate how
far from the bottom it needs to be.
If we tell it the leading constraint,
iOS can automatically calculate
the trending constraint,
based on the width of our green button.
So, the rule goes as follows, you need
a minimum of two constraints in each
dimension or axis, x and y, to
properly size and layout a UI element.
Except, if that UI element
has an intrinsic size,
then you only need one constraint for
each dimension or axis, x and y.
iOS can figure out the other
constraint based on the intrinsic size.
Last thing to remember,
when sending a constraint,
we're always comparing
one thing to another.
The record button placement is relative
to the UI view it's contained in,
in other words, its parent.
I've represented the UI view by
this blue rectangle outline.
Right now, the UI view is full screen.
But if we make it a different size,
the record button will be
still centered in that view.